the Apple watch is coming it'll be in
stores on April 24th for a starting
price of $349
going all the way up to at least $10,000
for the gold ones okay yeah yeah you can
buy this thing soon but today we also
learned what you can actually do with it
here are five things the Apple watch can
actually help you with breaking news
it's 12:30 and the Apple watch can tell
you the time there will be tons of watch
faces available you can choose them on
the watch or through the iPhone watch
app and customize them with different
layouts and colors then power reserve
mode will turn off other features and
keep the watch on mom is that you you
know it's me I'm calling from the Apple
watch the Apple watch can actually help
you communicate with people and some odd
and fun ways yes with a mic and speaker
built right in and when paired with your
iPhone you can make phone calls with the
watch you can also receive texts and
respond right from the screen but none
of that seems as personal as you know
sending your heart rate or a
disappearing doodle the Apple watch also
wants to help you get off your butt
seriously it's got a bunch of fitness
and health features like other fitness
bands it will track your movement and
nudge you to move more there's a heart
rate sensor that will check in on your
heart every few minutes
I wonder how accurate it will be though
you know it's smaller than your wallet
the Apple watch you can use the watch
instead of your iPhone with Apple pay
that's good news for iPhone 5s users
which can't use Apple pay at all now
lastly it sort of wants to help with
everything which I'm finding to be a
little bit overwhelming at launch there
be loads of apps that work with the
watch including uber and Instagram the
problem is that why there's a lot it can
do I'm not sure I need all of that on my
wrist we plan to have a full review of
the Apple watch closer to its
availability